i walked into my house yesterday from
outside
and literally a lanternfly was on my
neck a wet fly a lanternfly those
invasive things that are everywhere now
they are disgusting and i want them all
dead and i'll do everything
it's very pretty looking
good once you marry it
oh boy
what an attitude and they just they
literally cover a tree and they just did
to kill the tree maybe it's a message
that it's time for us to move on do you
ever think that us maybe we're the maybe
we're the pests and a bigger species is
coming in now i need this from you right
now i don't need this from you right now
you're the only person that he pulls up
an invasive species that is multiplying
over the last few years that scientists
are urging us to kill that have been
an invasive species look at what we've
done to the planet look at the trees
we've killed did they hire you as their
council why are you defending them oh
i'm sorry that the peach tree won't be
fruitful enough for mr sao volcano
anymore the birthday the birthday
episodes are over folks